The second question asked, what is the maximum number of edges in B.
We wrote a constructed graph with a maximum of edges,
and take each node and connect it to everything that we can.
This first node, I can only connect to the three other nodes on the right side.
I can't connect to anything else on the left side or else it wouldn't be a bipartite graph.
The second node also has three edges connecting to other nodes in the right side,
and we do the same for the other remaining nodes on the left side,
and we'll look at the nodes on the right side and this first node can't connect to anything else.
The second node can't connect to anything else and the third node can't connect to anything else.
For this graph, we can have 15 edges, and in general a bipartite graph
can have a maximum l * r edges--where l is the number of edges in the left group
and r is the number of edges in the right group.